foreign
welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel in this session we'll create a
virtual assistant using Python and name
him Jarvis he will be capable of telling
us the current date and time playing any
video on YouTube and searching
information through Wikipedia and do
many more tasks but before we begin if
you love watching Tech videos subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
now miss an update before starting let
us have a simple question to pressure
upon our knowledge and please answer in
the comment section below and we'll
update the correct answer in the print
comment so our first question is which
is one of the most popular python
library for WhatsApp and YouTube
Automation and the options are buy vote
kit tensorflow by torch or open ceiling
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
so let us start with our virtual
assistant
for that first we'll create a folder
and name it as creating
virtual assistant
and inside
we will open the python editor you can
use any editor
I am using the virtual Studio code for
our project for that I will be opening
the command prompt and writing the
command code space period
and press enter this will open the
visual studio code
and here we will create a file and name
it as Jarvis
Dot py
and now we can start our code
before starting let's have a basic
understanding of our virtual assistant
the basic function of the virtual
assistant is to listen and respond to
our instructions for that we will
install three simple python packages
we will open the Chrome browser
and search for the first package that
would be speech recognition
you could see that this is the website
for the speech recognition package we
will copy the command
and open a command prompt and we'll
paste the command here
and press enter to install it
as you can see that it states the
requirement is already satisfied as I
have already installed the speech
recognition package and you can also
write this command in your ideally in
the terminal there also you can install
that
so our first package is installed now we
will move to our second package there
could be
text to speech
Python and that is the version 3.
and this is the website for that we will
copy the command and
again move back to our Command Prompt
and paste a command and press enter
as you can see that the requirement is
already satisfied I have already
installed this module also
and our last module would be Pi audio
so this is the website for pi audio
package we'll copy the command and move
back to our Command Prompt
foreign and
press enter
as you can see I have already installed
all the packages and if you face any
issues while installing just comment
down in the comment section and we will
get back to you
so let's start
with a code and first we'll import our
packages
for the virtual assistant to understand
us we will import speech recognition
module and give it a name as AA for that
we'll write the command import
speech underscore
recognition
and name it as
a
now we'll create a listener and this
listener will hold a recognizer which
will recognize our voice
for that we will write the command oh
sorry because the name
just
okay
now we'll create a lesson
for that
we'll write the command list now equal
to a
dot recognizer
now we will place a try block it will be
a question if a microphone doesn't work
but if we Face any other app
for that
we will introduce the try block
spray
and an accept block
and just write a command pass here
so this means that python will do
nothing if an exception occurs
and inside the try block we'll use the
microphone for that we will type the
command and give it a name as origin
which will be the origin of our audio
for that we'll write the command
with
a a DOT
microphone
as origin
now we will create a new variable and
name it as speech and add a listener to
listen to this origin
for that we'll write the command
now we'll create a variable instruction
and recognize the origin voice and using
Google API we'll convert it to text for
that we'll write the command instruction
equal to
listener
don't recognize
underscore using the Google API for that
we'll write
Google
and inside will pass the speech
now we'll print the instruction given by
us the instruction is what we are
speaking to our assistant so we will
print that
and now we will write a command print
listening so that it would show
our assistant is ready to hear to us
when we will run the command or we will
run our whole project so it will take
some time to process all the code and
then it would print the statement
listening after that we could speak so
that our assistant could listen to us
and respond to us
for that
we'll write a command
print listening
so if there is an indentation mistake
now we will check whether a code is
working or not so this part of code
first we'll save it
and click on the Run button
okay so we got an error okay so there's
an indentation error
okay now we'll save it
and run it again yeah we can see that uh
our assistant responded as listening
so our code is working
as it can listen to us but it can't
respond to a size we have not imported
the text to speech module
so we'll work on that
now
we'll write a command to detect the word
Jarvis in the instruction as we are
giving the instruction and storing in in
the variable instruction
so as we are naming our assistant as job
is
let us detect the word Jarvis in it
for that
we'll use a conditional statement
first we will make a pole instruction in
lower case so that we won't get any
error
and we can detect it easily
now we have made it to lower case and
now we will use a conditional statement
to detect the word Jarvis
so for that we'll use the conditional
statement if
Jarvis
is present in an instruction
then
we'll print the instruction simply
so now if we give any instruction that
would be H always how is you so it would
detect the word Jarvis in it and it
would print the instruction and if it
doesn't contain the word Jarvis it won't
respond to an instruction it would just
listen to it and ignore that
now to respond back
we will import another package that
would be python text to speech
so this is the package
with the use of this package our
assistant can respond to us
now we'll create a variable
and name it as machine
and initialize with our python text to
speech module
for that we'll write
okay
there's a small mistake
now now we have initialized a python
text to speech audio
now we will Define a function
and name it as stock and we'll pass some
parameter that we want to hear
for that
Define the function and inside to pass
the parameter as text
and write the command machine dot C is
the function that would pass the
parameter and repeat it
repeat it mean it would could it would
give the output
so machine don't
run and wait
so every time we call the talk function
it will say the parameter will pass now
we will Define the function input
instruction it will manage all that we
say as an instruction to Jarvis
so
and we'll keep this drive block inside
the function only
now we'll Define
I mean we keep all this inside this
function
now we'll create another function for
Jarvis to include all the
functionalities the functionalities that
would be to play any video on YouTube to
talk back to
respond us back the date and time for
that
we will create another function
and name it as please have this
play underscore
Jarvis
now
inside this we'll create a variable and
name it as instruction
and we'll get it then other function
that is input instruction
in it
now
we will print this instruction
and make the instruction AS Global
variable
now we will add the functionalities and
the function play Javas
for that we will use the conditional
statements
and for that we'll write if
is present in our instruction
we will add some functionality to it
let me show
instruction okay so if play is mentioned
in an instruction or the speech we give
to our assistant it would do some
functionalities
mostly like it would play the videos on
YouTube
for that first we'll import the package
that would be pivot kit that makes the
automation of YouTube and WhatsApp
easily
I have already installed this packet so
you just need to enter the command paper
installed pivotkit in your terminal or
in the command Pro you can easily get it
installed and then you can import it
now
we will add the functionality and that
would be to talk back
the song name and it could say that it
was playing this song
so for that we'll call The Talk function
and inside
you can pass the word playing and plus
the instruction given by us you can
store it in the variable song
okay so that will create the variable
song
and side we will get our instruction
and
if we don't want to just get it written
or print the song name so that will
reduce the replace function
how does it work I will show you that
so it would just replace the keyword
play
and write all the other words that is if
I say Play Maroon 5 so it would just
print the Maroon 5 and won't print the
wordplay
and instead of play it would just print
an empty string
now we have imported the pivot kit
package
so we'll use it here
we will play on YouTube
and inside will pass the instruction
that is the song
and now to check this first where Kohler
function that is
playing it underscore
Jarvis
okay here and return the instruction
as the function is called in talk Jarvis
also that is Page always
and we're painting instruction two times
okay
yeah
and now we will add other
functionalities
okay now we will add more
functionalities to our assistant
it's real ID
now to add more functionalities
let's start with the command LF and
the next functionality we could add is
to
get current date and time from an
assistant
so for that first we need to import the
package date and time
as I am already installed it
you need to get it installed
so that you can use the command pip
space install space date time indoor
terminal or
in your command prompt
so here we will add the functionality
that is LF
time
so if time is present in our instruction
or the speech we are giving to our
assistant so it will just give us the
current time
so for that we'll write the command
instruction and now
time equal to
date time
Dot
date
time
dot now
dot strf time
foreign
which format we wanted we will write
that
that would be
percent I
sent
um
same p
no spaces in between
yeah
and we want to talk back our assistant
so for that better call The Talk
function
and inside we will ask him to talk back
that would be
current time
Plus
what would be the current time
okay so we have added the functionality
for the time and we will check it
before we will add the date also so we
should get the today's date also for
that we'll write the command else if if
date is present in our instruction
so update Android date time
to indeed
time dot now
let's try
and in which format you want it
that would be question d
percent M that would be the month
and at last would get it here
yeah that's where I read the
functionality and we won't as tend to
talk back to us
and what it would say that would be
today's date
that's a good
talk back that it to us
from now we'll add more functionalities
option after that we will check whether
it's working or not or if we have any
other error you will get it sorted after
that so
we could just add more functionality
that would be the basic grid
what are the suggests Trend could do to
us or make to respond to how are you
for that we will write LF
and if he listens how are you in an
instruction
so it would talk back to us and we're
going to be saying is
that I am fine and we would ask us also
like how about you
so
I am fine
how about you
foreign
like what's your name and his name is
Java so he should respond to that
so for that
we'll write another command that would
be as if
and
if
what is your name
is present in our instruction
it would talk back
foreign
yeah and
if there is an error move if somewhat
Jarvis doesn't hear
or we doesn't include Jarvis in our
instruction so he would say something to
us to please repeat the instruction or
something so for that
we'll write the command
and it would talk back to us
please repeat
these are the functionalities
[Music]
yeah okay we are left with the Wikipedia
we like
search information through Wikipedia so
for that we will import Wikipedia
and for that you need to install the
Wikipedia package for that you can
search on the Chrome Wikipedia Python
and copy the command from there and you
can paste it in your terminal or command
prompt and install it and then import it
so for that
write the command else if
and what should it look like who is or
what is
so when I put OS
and instruction
and that people
you know that
human
equal to
instruction
Dot
replace
first we are replacing who is from the
instruction like it shouldn't be printed
so for that
we are replacing it
and instead
we'll just get a string that is empty
string
information
Wikipedia dots somebody
and inside will pass the human
only
and then we will print time for
you will get all the information printed
about that command
and ask the assistant to talk back
all that information
okay
School
okay we are calling the function here
okay
yeah
and if we don't want Jarvis to be
included in our statement
so
you could write the command
that would be instruction
equal to instruction
dot replace
and what it should replace Jarvis from
the instruction it shouldn't print the
instruction
like it should print that section but
not the Jarvis in it
and instead of that
it will print just an empty string
now we'll save the file
and run a project
Jarvis what's the date today
so you can see that uh the date
function is working fine so we can check
all the other functions and we can check
it one by one
Jarvis what's the time now
current time is 11 37 am
Jarvis play simply learn
playing simple learn
Javas play Coldplay
plain cold
Jarvis who is Mahatma Gandhi
mohandis Karim John Gandhi Gandhi
October 2nd 1869 to January 30 1948 was
an Indian lawyer anti-colonial
Nationalist and political ethicist who
employed non-violent resistance to lead
the successful campaign for India's
independence from British rule and to
later Inspire movements for civil rights
and freedom across the world
so guys you can see that all the
functionalities are working with a
virtual assistant that is Jarvis
so
with that we have come to the end of
this session and I hope it was
interesting and informative if you liked
it please let us know in the comment
section below also do subscribe to our
Channel hit the Bell icon for more
updates
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign